good morning everybody uh welcome to
this latest meeting with the traffic
cover 19 public engagement board
um i have apologies this morning from
elliot and council accordingly
are there any further apologies
don't see any thank you
are there any declarations of interest
in today's agenda items
no thank you can we please take the
minutes of the meeting held on the 12th
of january as read and as a true and
accurate record
thank you
so that brings on to item four which is
our current update on the current kobe
19 situation in trafford
uh it's been a busy time for you i think
helen um various lots of things
happening i'll be interested to know
today uh what your advice is in relation
to um
the restrictions on mask wearing which
are obviously from tomorrow have gone uh
what your best advice is to residents in
trafford in keeping themselves safe
because we do know that this pandemic
has not gone away and as we've seen
there is a a stall in in infection rates
around our schools have been to see what
what you think about that as well so
without further ado thank you helen
thank you chair yes um it's been an
interesting couple of weeks for us in
public health but um as usual our
covered response team has really stood
up to the challenge so just to go
through the data very quickly with you
sorry let me just bring the
air report that our analyst sends us
every morning up onto the screen
and um so our figures now if i give you
a summary of the figures and i can um go
through some key points with you about
them so um
up to friday the 21st of january our
rate is eight six seven point nine so
that is a decrease on the seven days
previous which is at nine four oh uh but
you can see now we're starting to slow
but i think the interesting point to
make here is initially when we're in the
2000s
um
you know we had a high
rate to drop from so we had that real
fast escalation of a decline and now
we're starting just to slow a little bit
more
but just in terms of numbers for up to
friday the 21st of january
2062 of our residents tested positive
for covert
um in terms of our over 60s rate so this
is our vulnerable population that we
work
um that we watch very very carefully in
terms of our nursing home home care and
just keeping our communities safe so our
rates for the over 60s up to friday the
21st is at 379 per hundred thousand and
that again has declined so that's really
good to see that so that's declined from
five to six of the week previously
um in terms of our positivity so this is
the proportion who tests positive you go
for a test we that's decreased again so
we're on 20 but that is still much
higher than we would like to see and it
does demonstrate the amount of infection
circulating in the community
so i think when we met last time we
trafford where the ninth
lowest
ninth lowest in uh greater manchester
we're now um the third highest but i
think it's just recognizing the kind of
pinball effect that we're seeing with
the dropping rates and and the shift
that within our boroughs
so um the highest rate is tame side over
a thousand so one thousand seven uh per
hundred thousand and then barry at eight
179 and then we're just below that
um so we are watching that very
carefully as you can imagine
for geographies uh broad heath is our
highest award at the moment
um and that's over twelve hundred per
hundred thousand followed by astronaut
mercy but close saint martin brooklyn
and village so again you can really see
that spread across our borough there in
terms of where our infection rates lay
for ages um our age is the highest at
the moment for our 0-14 and i'll talk
about that again for you in a moment and
that's followed by our 30s to 44 year
olds
um and we are in general looking like
we're plattering
for hospital admissions um this is the
figure for all greater manchester
hospital emissions from all across
greater manchester and the numbers are
um
lower than they were the previous period
so that's really good to see and we're
also seeing a slight decline in number
of people who are occupying ventilated
beds as well
and so that suggests to us that people
who are being admitted to hospital
aren't as poorly as in previous waves
and again that's testament to the
success of the booster programme
sadly people in trafford
are still dying from
covid
but again fortunately our numbers remain
reasonably stable
and um are small um i use the word
fortunately then i didn't mean to say
that because any death from kovid is
obviously a tragedy so it is something
that we take incredibly seriously and
watch very carefully
so key messages um i just wanted to
share with you let me just bring up my
notes sorry
um
so the case rates have started to level
out
um
and we're looking forward looking that
that's going to continue for the next
couple of days
trafford's rate of testing has mostly
been highest among the gm
borough and that this is continuing
trend as well so we're seeing our rates
increase in terms of testing
apart from our zero to 14 year olds case
rates have dropped for all ages from
january the 4th
um our 0-14 incident has been volatile
since january the 4th so that's when
schools reopened and there has been an
upward trend since january the 13th and
13th
for most recent days um our 30-44 year
olds are following the same trend but if
you think about that age group that's
likely to be the parents of those kids
and it's predominantly primary schools
that we're seeing activity in at the
moment but kirsty can talk us through
that
um
and what we're also seeing is a slight
uptick with our 45 to 59 year olds as
well
um
testing is low in our primary school
group but positivity is high which
demonstrates the amount of infection
circulating
um
and the national modelling doesn't
suggest a projected surge in cases over
the next few weeks so that's just some
key messages from our analyst tom there
really around the data so what we are
seeing then is a cluttering of cases but
an increase in our um
in our sorry just trying to get back to
my main screen in our
school-aged children at the moment
so um
sorry i can't find my zoom screen
is it gone i can hear you i think
too many things what's going on here
sorry
we can still see you
can you say i can't see you which is
really odd so i'll just work that out in
a minute but i continue with my notes
and i'll try and find out what's going
on
so um because we'll talk you through our
outbreaks but we continue to be busy in
terms of our care homes and our primary
schools in particular ben's here to talk
us through um
testing but there's been some
significant changes in testing which
you'll be aware of and
in terms of looking at our data it's
understanding the impact that that
testing policy has had so we do expect
that drop-in rates to be
a drop in um infection rates true
infection rates in the population but
it's also thinking very much about um
the number of people who may not be
registering their positive tests
um on the system so that's something we
need to really impress on our population
is to continue to register
your lfd or your um
your lfd test
and including your negative lfd test as
well to give us a good oversight of
what's going on
um in terms of restrictions for face
coverings
face coverings
are really to be used in our secondary
school population our advice has been
and we work really closely with our head
teachers and we do have a listening
session tomorrow afternoon with our head
teachers
has been that we will support any of our
head teachers who
wish to continue the wearing of face
coverings in secondary schools so that's
the position we we've
taken alongside a number of other
different um boroughs across greater
manchester for those schools in outbreak
which our outbreak could work with face
covering um the reintroduction of face
covering is a necessary intervention um
and that's something that we again would
support in part of the contingency
planning which kirsty can talk you
through
so our position really in trafford is we
would support any schools to continue
with the um
use of face coverings going forward um
and it's it's about us working with the
schools in that but we we
obviously
um
support the use of face coverings in
outbreak in terms of
other measures i think we have to be
really careful to remember that the
pandemic isn't over
uh yes people haven't been as unwell
with omicron as they were with delta but
delta is still circulating we're still
seeing people poorly
and so we need to continue to be
cautious and we need to continue with
our covered secure kind of actions so if
you're out and about in a crowded space
busy place then do wear your face
coverings uh social distances remain two
meters away ventilation is really
important um hand hygiene and
respiratory hygiene so if you do feel
poorly you know think twice about going
into the office
and just because you test never negative
on an lft
doesn't mean that you know by feeling
poorly it's the right thing to do to go
into work so if you can work from home
and you just feel mildly and well and
stay at home
but also it's the testing element as
well isn't it to make sure that if you
do have symptoms you go and have a pcr
test so we would remain cautious um
at the moment but we are watching and
working very closely with gm colleagues
regional colleagues and national
colleagues to to understand what the
next actions are we're awaiting
publication of a living safely with
covid policy from uh national government
which will give us some direction going
forward but locally we are at the moment
reviewing what actions we need to take
um
into the into the new year and through
the summer
so thank you and i'll try and find you
now back on my screen hopefully
uh thank you helen before i look for
questions have you any advice to
residents in relation to
the continued wearing of maths say for
example enclosed spaces supermarkets
shopping
yeah we would support that i think we
have to continue to be cautious and
we would recommend the continued wearing
of face coverings in any busy spaces any
you know if you're going supermarket
shopping um it's just really good
practice really good hygiene in terms of
covid so that is something that we would
support as a local team but obviously
it's it put people's decisions as to
whether um they do continue with face
coverings because it's no longer a
mandated requirement
thank you are there any questions please
from anybody
judith
you're on mute
yeah um
just
apparently i was reading yesterday that
um some people are actually getting
repeat covered infections they're not
ill because they've been jabbed uh well
certain not very ill and are we keeping
any figures on that
hello yeah yeah we are so we're starting
to get tom our analyst it will be
starting in the next few weeks to
receive re-infection rates so we're
going to look to see what that data
looks like and how
accessible it is in terms of
understanding the patterns but as soon
as we get it we will be building it into
our regular data updates as well so that
is something we're looking to
but yes there is a lot of evidence
around people
having uh covered on more than one
occasion
thank you helen i've got a question
actually and it relates actually to the
flu jab
uh having read in the press that there's
just no flu around this year i i i our
people still get have we had a big
uptake in uh uh
with people wanting food jumps
as everyone who's got a flu job got one
basically
uh so obviously there's been a high
profile flu vaccination program this
year we vaccinate um
our school-aged children and mark is
probably best to discuss the primary
care uptake but it is
we we have a surveillance program that
looks to watch out for flu vaccination
flu
infections particularly in our more
complex settings so our care homes so
that is something we are actively
monitoring at the moment um
there have been reported cases but none
in trafford as yet so we are just
watching that very carefully numbers are
very low um and i don't know if mark
wanted to come in around the vaccination
element but it is something that we
reinforce uh each winter the importance
of flu vaccination but this year in
particular
yes certainly
so
we yes last year um with the covered
vaccinations flu vaccinations were
significantly higher than we'd ever
achieved previously and also the social
distancing reduces the transmission of
flu in just the same way as it reduces
the transmission of kovid so flu was
almost unheard of last year um helen's
correct and that it there's been a very
low incidence this year
um
it's difficult for us to know whether
that is due to the flu jab which
i haven't got the exact figures to hand
at the moment but has been you know more
successful than previous years um i'm
not sure we're quite at the same level
as last year yet but i can find that
information out for you and share with
you um
but you we're still
benefiting also from the social
distancing re reducing the transmission
of flu because you know the omicron
and the anxiety around that over the
last couple of months has significantly
affected people's behaviors
and it is
sort of the end of december
and january that is the peak incidence
period for flu usually
thank you mark that's very very useful
judith you got a question
yeah i would be interested in the flu
uptake because actually i've only just
had mine and i'm in that um age group
unfortunately when
i need it but um
i just wondered if there have been
delays because i know there's an optimum
time for people to have the flu job
which is early in the season
which i think is october november
you're absolutely right judith it has
been a more prolonged
vaccination
program this year because the supplies
from the manufacturers
have come in
more of a steady
delivery throughout the period rather
than just getting
getting you know most of them delivered
in the first
two weeks so we usually get a large
proportion end of september start of
october
and we want to use them as quickly as
possible because the longer they sit in
the fridge with greater risk of them
deteriorating but this year the
deliveries two practices have been
spread out
over a prolonged period so yes i've i've
vaccinated people this week
because you know the supplies have meant
that that's been the position
um
yeah the you know like i say the
benefits and the
lower rates are probably just as much
due to
the social distancing that we've all
come to do in a different way previously
as the the increased uptake of the
vaccination
thank you mark any further questions at
all before we move on the next agenda
item uh before before we do helen i
don't see kirsty on the call yet can
someone give her a nudge since she's
after ben
and we'll move on to ben uh on
mass testing welcome ben
good morning chair um good morning
everyone so a few updates then on
testing
first of all let's do um something on
stock availability so as i mentioned a
couple weeks ago we had huge demand
electric flow tests across the country
in each other um with many people
struggling to get a hold of them the
good news is that more more stock has
started to come back into the system so
by and large people are now able to get
hold of tests um our own testing team
have been helping out with this by
ensuring that libraries have been
stocked up and we have our departments
in library to little locations that can
give out tests and we've also been
enabling key groups so health and social
care staff businesses etc to get tests
by either drop-off or collection i did a
look at the figures yesterday and we
finally broke through a hundred thousand
tests
given out in the past six weeks and it
took us 26 weeks previously to do the
same amount we've done in six weeks so a
really really huge effort from the team
otherwise outbreaks are we still
supporting outbreaks when needed we had
a mobile test unit at primary school
earlier this week and carried out 170
tests which is a really high number and
the key benefit there is it helps reduce
the spread of covert and crucially as it
helps to keep school open at this time
um
otherwise testing guidance changes so
this feels like it happened ages ago but
it's actually only last monday um that
the guidance on self-isolation changed
and so those in self-isolation have the
option to reduce the isolation period if
they test negative on both day five and
six
so individuals who are positive on the
electrical flow test have to still stay
in isolation until they've had two
consecutive negative tests on separate
days so essentially you can start
testing on day five and you need to self
isolate till you've got two negative
tests taken 24 hours apart or you've
been in self isolation for that 10 day
period
and then finally then just on some key
messages
um so a just please continue to watch
your flow test before you see other
people um i know you don't need that
confirmatory pcr test anymore unless you
um you're requesting the self-isolation
support payments um but as helen
mentioned if you have symptoms any kind
of symptoms whatsoever don't be lying a
lot to flow tests please go out and get
yourself a pcr test that's still really
really important at this time and that's
the key messages from me jeff
thank you ben um any questions for ben
at all
uh can i just refer back to the the
group chat helen there's a question in
there from uh
from council welton which says rates
seem very high in schools still is this
translating to any serious illness among
children easy hospitalization
you're on mute i think
apologies this morning i'm having i.t
gremlins it's great when it works it's
awful when it doesn't work isn't it um
so interestingly we had a meeting last
week with the clinical pediatric lead
national lead simon kenny really
interesting meeting where fortunately we
are not seeing significant illness in
children so we are seeing high activity
but not significant illness um and
that's that's really good to see and i
think
the added bonus is that we have
high um
booster uptake rates across traffic as
well that adds they added protection
into the homes
so no so um it's reassuring to see that
in terms of children and the thinking is
as well with each wave if we do have any
further waves what they've seen
previously is the level of severity of
illness in children um becomes less with
each wave that we see so again that's a
really important message there thank you
thank you thank you i i don't see the
next time for kirsty but is jill are
going to take this one outbreak
management and uh
contact racing
he's just in a meeting at the moment and
i'll ask her to join if possible
well john i thought i'll want to move on
to mass vaccination then and and hold it
thank you so we'll move on to mass
vaccination invite uh martin
mark sorry mark sorry biggie pardon it's
all right i was about to say did you
mean me
um
so the after a
what i've got to say was a huge success
of our vista campaign in in december
um where
we vaccinated over 30 000 people
during the three weeks of december
um which resulted in us getting
um by the end of december
over eight percent of the eligible
people
boosted i have to say eligible because
boosters are different this is the over
18s and those who are more than three
months after having had their second
jab so it's it's not the whole
population and the figures the way the
figures have been presented in in
different arenas have been
a little confusing at times so
we we cur we've continued to do the
boosters and we're now up to
over 82 of those eligible for a booster
have been boosted
so we did brilliantly
towards the end of december the rates
were slowing down and there was an
increasing number of people who were
unable to attend their appointment
because
they actually had coved
and we've got a publicity campaign going
out reminding those people that they are
eligible for their vaccination 28 days
after their infection and encouraging
them to still have it because
the best protection
um comes from having had the vaccination
as well as the infection
for those who have it so that's ongoing
the rate of vaccination has dropped so
of the last couple of weeks we've only
been doing about 2 000
vaccinations per week across trafford
but we are now mopping up
um
the
more difficult to reach groups because
we've got
well over eighty percent of our
population had one vaccination about
eighty percent have had two
and
were doing a desperate catch up to get
the vaccinations of the boosted
vaccine population over 80 as they all
become eligible
um
so
we've got plenty of capacity across
trafford in our various locations to be
able to deliver to all of those
that are eligible
um
helen and
her community engagement team are doing
a lot of work in the areas where the
rates
of uptake have been lower
because unfortunately at the start of
the
started booster campaign
those who were keen and active came and
got their boosters and widened the gaps
um for a while and we're still trying to
narrow that again um
but you know we've
it's become more a business as usual
again from this point of onwards we've
got lower numbers and harder to reach to
to get to
and then we've got
changes like the vulnerable five to 11
year olds who
are
being made eligible but the
detailed operational detail of how that
has to be delivered has not yet been
um released so that the campaign has not
yet been started um so it's it's
changing we're still vaccinating people
we're trying to ensure we've got an
offer to cover the whole population and
everything that is recommended and i'm
confident we cover that at the moment
and we will continue to
pick up all those remaining that that we
can actually manage to
convince they should have their job
i probably ought to also mention that
you'll have seen in the press there's
there's a bit of debate at the moment
about all healthcare staff and if the
legislation does go through parliament
or
patient-facing healthcare staff will
have to be vaccinated for the double
vaccinated before the 1st of april which
means they've got to have their first
vaccination before the 3rd of february
so there's some additional work going on
about
communication and
conversations with
anybody working in a healthcare
environment and their
requirement to have that the legislation
isn't yet in place
um
but
well it depends which paper you read and
which opinion here as to whether that is
still going to be
um
completed in time for that first of
april deadline
so i'll i'll do my best to answer any
questions mike thank you i think it
really has been a fantastic effort on
the whole vaccination program
and the booster programme and and it's a
big thanks to
all of everyone who's been involved from
the ccg the pharmacist and the community
engagement team and our public health
team
in doing this it really has you know i
think trafford is probably and you
probably confirm this mark we're
probably the best uh performing borough
in terms of boosters and vaccination
across gm and it's no small thanks to
all of those including the volunteers as
well i must add them in as well
absolutely
any questions at all please for mark
yes um hi sorry sorry go on so it's okay
it's this is really good news and i'm
really pleased to hear that we're going
in the right direction and as a
voluntary organization we've really
valued um the information and advice and
guidance that has come out to us but
what we found recently in relation to
the point you've made about um the
changes in guidance for healthcare staff
is that it's a little bit confusing um
because the guidance actually says that
it relates to people or organizations
that are cqc
registered and providing personal care
and support but if you're not if you're
a voluntary organization cqc registered
and you provide um
care to people
not in nottingham not on the regulated
activity then i think the guidance
actually says that those people
providing that support do not need to be
vaccinated and i think the and i've
contacted the cqc i've looked at the
flowcharts and it really is confusing as
to how that guidance is applied to
organizations like ours who use
volunteers we provide um support to
people sometimes in their homes and also
in community settings it is a little bit
confusing
um
don't don't feel bad about that because
you're not the only person who is
confused you're absolutely right the
guidance currently says
that it is anybody working in a cqc
regulated service or environment
which
is very difficult because the ccg that i
work for
is not cqc regulated
and the members of our team who work
alongside other providers who are
regulated
you know
it's not clear in legislation whether
they absolutely must be vaccinated
although you're we're working on the
principle they should be
because they are working alongside
others in cqc regulated activities
but you're absolutely right the guidance
is
at this point in time
um open to interpretation which is not
great
and
you know
legally
i would suspect that at the moment your
volunteers would not necessarily have to
be vaccinated unless they were working
in the premises of or alongside somebody
who is cqc regulated
but practically
you know it would be in everybody's best
interest you know it the the greater
good to have
everybody who is having patient or
contact with others you know vaccinated
because it reduces the risk of
transmission reduces the risk of passing
on infection um so you know as a
as a more broad your well-being point we
don't want everybody vaccinated if at
all possible particularly those who have
taken on any form of caring or support
responsibility
absolutely i absolutely agree
but from a provider's perspective and
particularly with issues around
recruitment it's becoming very
challenging
um just to make that point
absolutely and this this has been raised
at a national level there's a number of
things you know this is national
guidance that we're we're doing our best
to apply locally um
so
but it has been raised by multiple
people because of the the difficulties
it is causing
okay thank you
thank you for raising that dorothy i
think it it it's clearly
um a very confusing area
and i'll take your point about the the
makes recruitment a lot more difficult
for organizations like yours
but thank you also mark for that quite
clear explanation of the expectations
um any further questions at all
no um
can we just move on to community
engagement uh helen and then because i
don't see kirsty on the call yet
at all
hi chad kirsty's um in an outbreak
control meeting this morning so she sent
me an update
well okay well i'll bring you in then on
the on the outbreak management contact
racing thank you thank you and apologies
zoom really doesn't like me this morning
i don't know what i've done to offend it
i've got i've got two pictures of you
one frozen and one live
she won't wish that on anyone to be fair
i'm sorry right so um this is an update
from kirsty who's our outbreak um hub
manager so in terms of complex settings
our schools remain busy with inquiries
and cases particularly in primary
schools big difference in case numbers
in primaries compared to secondaries
we've had 23 primaries without breaks
since returning after christmas but only
three high schools with small outbreaks
so you can really see the difference
there the thinking um is potentially
that that older cohort of young people
may have some acquired immunity already
from the infections that we saw in
september but also we have to remember
the 12 to 15 vaccination program so that
hopefully is offering some protection to
our older young people
high cases in early years which is
decreasing
um but we've seen high numbers in a in
our early years staff group so we're
doing some work there so when we talk
earlier this is nursery provision really
uh predominantly we see um young female
workforce so jilla and colleagues have
been doing lots of work around that kind
of fertility messaging and support for
for young people
young women in particular inquiries
around testing scenarios so lots of the
hubs receiving lots of questions around
the 90-day rule so if you've had a
positive case
of covid then you don't pcr tests for 90
days unless you are symptomatic but
obviously the lfd change
the lfd
rule has changed so you can um lfd rule
test within 90 days so that's you know
lots of questions coming into the hub
about that
and we did see a really large increase
in workplaces
and outbreaks after christmas but that's
now reducing
um and kirsty works alongside nicola and
our regulatory team and they have a
prioritization framework for our
businesses
and all businesses are followed up and
offered advice that's really important
that we keep our you know economy
running in trafford and provide support
where we can
in terms of the local contact racing so
these are the cases that flow down to
our system when national can't get hold
of
the positive case so since christmas our
local team has contacted 3600 cases have
come through into our local team
some because of the demand have been
passed up to the national system again
but that's following prioritization
we have seen a dip in completion rate so
that's the number of people who've had a
conversation around contact tracing um
but i think what's important to mention
is that we've seen that across all
boroughs because of the demand and
trafford has the second highest
completion rate in the whole of greater
manchester so again something to be
congratulated on
um
they've set up a new system to
prioritize some postcode so if it is
particularly busy um we get those cases
through first from certain postcodes
across the borough
and that's where we've looked at our
obviously our intelligence and our
public health information around
deprivation and vaccine uptake as well
there's continued support for people who
have to self-isolate
and the final point from kirsty is the
self-isolation pathfinder
um is currently underway by an external
evaluation team and our residents have
been contacted to see if they'll be
willing to take part in the evaluation
so that's the key points from the
outbreak hub they have been really busy
um and have again been supporting adult
social care
alongside the ipc team in terms of um
supporting our care homes and supported
accommodation to remain open and safe
during the covered
period as well so where they've had
cases providing specialist advice so it
has been incredibly busy and
the team have stepped up incredibly well
thank you
thank you for that update and i i do
agree with you i think that um
when the national team was sent was it a
700 increase they had i think it was
reported two weeks ago in terms of the
number of people to try and trace and i
think they've done a fantastic job
am i still right uh helen that if
somebody
tests
uh is asymptomatic and tests positive
but needs financial support they must go
and get uh a pcr test to quality yeah if
they go for a pcr they qualify for the
self-isolation payment and that's got to
that pcr just has got to be within the
self-isolation period to be valid is
that yeah absolutely yeah yeah thank you
are there any questions at all uh
on outbreak management contact tracing
i don't see any at all uh thank you so
come in and move on to uh community
engagement and danny's going to update
us on the work that the team have been
doing thank you danny
hi thanks chad yeah so um the team is
continuing to support the 12-15
vaccination program um in the secondary
schools
so we're currently in talks with schools
to see how we can most effectively get
messages to parents and families and
we've approached skills that can
possibly do work
and before the consent deadline
and this offers going to be sessions in
classrooms and with the possibility of
questioning answer sessions as well with
the parents
and we've also got a video that can set
around to the parents as well explaining
the 12 to 15 vaccination programme
and what we're also going to do is uh
mention the out of school offer and
that's something that we'll try and ask
our skills about as well
including the skills that i've already
and have the vaccination team visit as
well and this is to make the families
aware that if their child isn't able to
be vaccinated in school that there are
other opportunities as well
and just also as well recently we've
supported the vaccination pop-up clinics
at the two college sites as well so in
alton river and stratford
and we've been able to have conversation
with the students um just around the
back team
and sign posted him towards the clinic
as well
um which from the feedback that we've
got has really helped to increase the
uptake just in that population as well
and we had a nice case of talking to one
of the individuals as well one of the
students who was anxious about getting
the vaccine so we're able to talk and
talk to them and support them through
that process as well
and the final thing is and just got a
couple of things projects planned in the
next couple of months
uh one's an arts project and that's in
the secondary schools
and where i want to get the students to
capture their experiences of the
pandemic
and we're also going to take this to one
of our some of our focus groups as well
and open up to their younger family
members as well and so they can create
something similar
thanks
thank you danny um i'll i've just done
the vaccination for 15 to 18 year olds
and and getting into schools um just to
just to say there are very very many of
our elected members that are our
governors at senior schools and that you
could tap into them to get them to to
encourage schools to to engage or and
maybe if you supplied them with
the access to the video they can they
can get that into the school
another way and also they will have
contacts with parents with parent
teacher associations as governors and
they can possibly assist
yeah thanks for that
i have any questions at all for for
danny from anywhere
i don't see any uh can i just say that
thank you for the continued work and i
know community engagement's been really
key for us right the way through this
uh and uh you know there's some
fantastic work that's been done
um
is there any other business at all for
this meeting
i don't see any i think we're gonna yes
uh helen please come in
sorry enormous zoom confusion i'm not
sure if i mentioned that we are looking
doing some forward uh planning now in
terms of that living safely with covid
covert isn't endemic in trafford at the
moment we're quite a long way off it's
still very much in an active pandemic
but as a public health team in a wider
system we are reviewing now what we need
to do going forward so i think um
for the next purp we may be able to
bring some further information in terms
of what we plan to do particularly for
uh 2022-2023
so i thought that'd be helpful for
members to be aware that we are very
much forward planning where we can
obviously there's a lot of unknowns on
lots of different levels but we are
working as best as we can to plan ahead
thank you helen uh you know i do agree
with you actually i think we await the
uh the government guidance on living
with um
kobe 19 uh with interest
uh but i think you absolutely are right
you know we still are in the pandemic in
traffic you can see that with the
infection rates uh uh you know that are
still there so um if there's no further
business we'll meet again in a fortnight
these meetings will continue i think
until such time as we we've got some
certainty going forward
i think they've been very very useful in
terms of the coverage we've had from
outside george do you want to come in
no no sorry sorry uh i think we've had
some very good coverage and and it's
highlighted some excellent work that has
been just gone on in trafford so again
my thanks as chair to the public health
teams the engagement team to ccg the
volunteers the vaccination program
people everything uh and and we will
meet again in in two weeks time thank
you very much indeed